how can we quickly square any four digit
number let's see
let's say we want to square 7009
firstly we will divide the number into
two parts let us take the first digit
from the left and the remaining will be
the second part after that we divide the
answer into three parts on the left side
we will write the square of the first
part that is seven squared in the middle
and on the right side we will have just
three digits in the middle we will have
two times seven times zero zero nine on
the right side we will have the square
of the last part that is 0 0 9 the whole
squared so we have 7 squared which is 49
the product of the middle part is 126
and on the right side we have 0 8 1.
always remember we have to write 3
digits in the middle and on the right
hand side hence we have to write 0 8 1
and not 81.
so on solving this further we get the
answer of 7009 squared
similarly here's the working of 6081 the
whole square
after solving this we get this answer
now using the same concept can you tell
us the answer to this question in the
comment section
if you liked the video please hit the
like button and subscribe to our youtube
channel now
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below